so from whom did yoga
originate Lord Shiva among the great
deities of Hinduism most personifies the
practice of yoga you will see the
picture of him from a temp in at a
temple where he seated under tree of
knowledge and sha is a god of knowledge
and so he's crushing the male child
ringer male child and as you can see
there's always a serpent with him and uh
then there's always a
trident a pitchfork a trident you can
say and then his feet as you can see are
Bine feet Bine cow oh okay so like C is
that say c like baale or something yeah
and most of those temples of daksham
Muti form of Shiva they are built facing
the South because he's a south facing
creature in other words the devotees
have to face the sides of the North
I will Ascend the sides of the north
above the clouds be like the most high
so when a person is practicing yoga they
are linking their mind with
[Music]
shivas what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at LED live we have a special
guest today Ivan Raj he's got a website
called yoga unboxed and he's going to
get into a presentation just talking
about the deceptions of yoga how it's
infiltrated our society America and yeah
man thank you for being on thank you so
much Mikey for inviting me to be with
you guys thank you you know yoga just
seems like it's like everywhere in the
US is it the same in India no it's not
actually um in India yoga is not as big
as is as it is in the US wow in India
people pract people exercise but it's
mostly non yoga exercises interesting
yes I assume everybody did yoga in India
no no not and even in America when we
talk about this topic like in the
comments people say well well how am I
supposed to stretch or what can I do
they act like yoga is the only option
and yet you're saying the the exact
opposite that in India they're not even
doing yoga but they're still exercising
and stretching AB absolutely and uh my
response to the Western Christians who
are into yoga if you want want to find a
non- yoga stretching talk to an Indian
oh that's interesting yeah that's so
cool I I mean you know we've we've
tackled this topic a few times on our
show before and just this intertwined
sort of spiritual experience with this
with this activity um you know a lot of
people say oh you know I'm not doing the
spiritual stuff I'm just doing the
activity but you know that that I think
is the hardest thing for people to wrap
their mind around yeah and how many
stories have we heard where people say
you know I did it because I had a back
injury I was stretching and then people
said hey you can meditate it just helps
relieve stress and the next thing you
know they're you know communicating with
ascended masters and they're full on in
the New Age yes so it's this slippery
slope and and in the beginning people
are saying oh it's not spiritual it's
just a stretching but I've heard it over
and over and over it always not always
but a lot of times goes that direction
if you tell a devote Hindu I'm just
doing yoga for stretching I'm not in
Hinduism uh I don't practice yoga for
the
spirituality uh the Hindu may get
offended because yoga is a Hindu ritual
wow I mean I I we've we've made this
comparison before but I guess if
somebody was praying but like I'm not
praying to your God you know it I could
understand that if you're doing that
activity that's typically associated
with that spiritual exercise or like hey
could I get baptized at your church oh
you accepted Christ no I just I just
want to do the baptism thing go under
the water yeah that's exactly correct uh
we can take an instance from Ezekiel um
chapter 8 uh where um the prophet
Ezekiel is taken by the Lord to
different compartments in the sanctuary
and there uh God shows Ezekiel that the
Believers the 25 Israelites men they had
their backs to God's Temple but they
were bowing to the sun yeah and God
calls that as the greatest abomination
and these are believers in the church
Sanctuary but and they're not chanting
all they're doing is bowing prostrate is
the right U uh uh word um and um so if
you look for the word the root word
there for Bowing it says to prostrate
and so they were bowing to Sun Su and
God calls as the greatest Abomination
today it is called in the US it's called
Sun salutation yeah so the actual word
is suya namaskara suryya means Sun
namaskara actually means worship so
people are worshiping the son the same
exact thing that happened in the time of
Ezekiel is happening today in the US in
Christianity well you're making me think
of shadat mesach and abedo too there was
a statue all they had to do was bow
their bodies they didn't have to
literally worship the thing but they
said we won't even bow to your image
even if we get thrown into the fire we
won't do it and yet Christians are
openly doing the sun's salutation yes
and also it's because most of the
leadership today uh you know they allow
in Christian churches like I'm not
allowed to speak about the Hindu origins
of yoga in certain Church big churches
really uh yeah because uh they have said
that no we don't want U lose our
membership because we have a lot of
youngsters in our church after covid and
we don't want to associate with what
you're doing so we'd rather water down
the truth to keep members there we don't
want to offend them that's that's a
perfect definition of the last days you
know the ear tickling and things that
are going to happen in the last days
they they'll turn away from sound
Doctrine and give heed to uh the well
seducing spirits and doctrines of demons
but also Feelgood messages and all that
absolutely wow man so I'm interested to
see what you got in this presentation
brother so the primary person for yoga
when it comes to yoga is a is a person
named patan
and uh he is called as the author of all
yoga
principles all yoga gurus who have been
trained you know they call ryt
registered yoga teacher um 300 or 500
that is basically 300 hours or 500 hours
um so they all would know
paneli and he is called as the author of
all yoga principles now when we when
somebody wants to look into the life of
this
character called
pangali who is the author of all of the
yoga principles whether it is meditation
or stretching and all of that people's
people attributed to
patanjali but who is
pangali generally in Hindu U websites uh
they state that he lived around 2,000
years ago or 1500 years ago or 2500
years ago approximately and nobody
really knows where exactly he lived
however
who was
he when we look into who was
penell it tells uh one of the Hindu
website tells that um he was an ancient
serpent
W I've heard this story before yeah
right so ADI sesha sesha means serpent
ADI means Ancient Ancient serpent not
only that he has another name as well
and uh he's also called as a wise ananta
ananta means
wisdom so basically patanjali is ancient
wise serpent wow and he wrote the
principles of yoga that everybody
practices today it's like there's like
one story and they just keep finding
different angles to tell the one story
to all the different cultures I mean
that's fascinating I'm surprised it's
not any older than 2000 years ago H I
think it would be older than that yeah
but uh we're going to come we're going
to talk about one more
character who was more ancient than
paneli we getting to that few slides the
truth really will set you free and as
Christians we have um an advantage
because imagine if you just never heard
the Bible ever and you hear well all
around the world people worship serpents
and there's this Crown you know serpent
that needs to go to my crown chakra and
and all you hear is this one angle that
he's wise that he wants to open your
eyes he wants to give you wisdom he
tells you you're like God then that's
going to look like this is the truth
because you hear it all around it's in
cultures everywhere but we have the
Bible that says no he was the one that
deceived humanity and that's why we're
in this big mess and yet the whole world
will worship him you know it says that
the the dragon that old serpent deceives
the whole world and yet we see it right
there so
was was
Kundalini uh yoga like one of the first
kinds because of his association with a
serpent or was that that serpent piece
kind of always there from the
beginning so the serpent piece was uh
always there from the beginning uh but
even before that the primary
um name associated to yoga is
Shiva and we're going to look into who
is Shiva the Destroyer yeah the
Destroyer yeah mhm so there's a serpent
around his
neck and uh so wherever there is uh
Shiva except for certain forms but most
of the forms of Shiva there's always a
serpent especially a cobra not just any
serpent not like a
rattlesnake Cobra why why the Cobra just
is the king of the snakes because it is
the most wisest of the serpent species
according to science first of all I want
to also establish what is yoga the word
yoga means uh unite to yoke and it is
from a root word called yug Sanskrit
Sanskrit is a spiritual language for
Hinduism actually one of the spiritual
languages the other one is Tamil uh but
predominantly Sanskrit is used in
Hinduism for
chance and um so yoga means to unite
basically the word yoga and the word
religion is one and the same religion is
from a Latin word the word English word
religion is from a Latin word called
religio which means to yoke to bind so
whether I say I'm practicing a religion
or practicing yoga is one and the same
wow that's and yoga is uh one of the six
schools of Hindu
philosophies and yoga is
atheistic atheistic they don't believe
in gods or because uh they they believe
in Guru the belief is the emphasis in
yoga is on the guru the master like
martial arts more like a prophet what
the other five so the five uh the five
other schools are about um chantings and
it's about
um um what is it
called
remedies remedies and uh way of life
such type of uh act uh teachings whereas
when it comes to yoga it is the
Practical arm of the atheistic part of
Hinduism so these are called The Yoga
sutras which
pangali uh before he took the human form
he was the ancient wise Serpent and then
he took the human form he became pangali
and then he wrote that's what Hinduism
claims that he wrote These yoga
principles now there are four chapters
here and this is in Sanskrit four
chapter
and in the second
chapter uh is the eight limbs of
yoga so I'm sure many of us and the
viewers many of the viewers would know
of eight loss of Health from the Bible
in yoga there are eight
limbs and um one of the limbs in the
eight limb is the posture the
as yeah and uh usually people uh stick
to this um
the teachings in this chapter because
the other chapters are extremely
complicated to achieve uh basically the
ultimate goal of yoga is the you know
you become one with the universe m in
other words what it means is I lose my
identity the eye the Atma the inner man
will dissolve into the universe so
that's what they call the ego death now
a lot of people reaching that with iasa
and DMT trip and all that so it's just
like it's it's an exact counterfeit of
what the Bible says die to yourself die
to the lust of the flesh the things that
are naturally in us we need to die to
those things but yeah Satan has a
counterfeit for everything yeah so so
these are the the all of the Yoga
practices and everything about yoga will
fit into this one
page wow interesting in the first
chapter of the yoga Sutra which we just
saw in the previous picture
um it says the definition is the
Restraint of the modifications of the
Mind in other words if your mind is
going to keep on thinking you have to
still that you have to control it and
bring it to a pause in other words no
transformation
required so that's why they say look
within yourself not up but within
yourself
and uh of course the Bible says the
opposite of that Philippians 2:5 let
this mind be in you which is also in
Christ
Jesus and so the Bible teaches to have
the mind of Christ to be selfless amen
the Bible teaches God is love Hinduism
teaches Love Is God self the feeling of
love that is divine mhm you find that
within yourself yes within yourself yes
yeah yes yeah very
interesting right the difference between
Jesus you know his mind was so others
Focus that he he was willing to lay down
his life so that you have an opportunity
to live that's the mind of of Jesus
right and it's like the whole
counterfeit is no it's inside of you and
you just need to work on you and don't
worry about anyone else you just worry
about you yeah it's interesting yeah
what is the definition of love to them
just an emotion a feel emotion emotional
driven yeah yes and the Bible says the
heart is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked who can know it you
can't follow your emotions you can't
follow your heart that's going to lead
you in all kinds of different directions
you followed her heart yeah wow very
good point next is uh another uh Sutra
or wise saying that patanjali supposedly
wrote is the divine within us is ever
enlightened and it is the by the way
this is actually the description
published by yoga International website
and that basically there is Divinity
within the human wow wow you are like
God you will be like Gods yeah see what
I mean like they got one story and they
literally just keep working on this one
story from different angles to every
culture it's it goes all the way back to
the Garden of Eden exactly so it's the
same template same product but the
labeling is different MH same exact
product and you'll find the same
teaching in other religions also uh for
example in Buddhism uh they talk about
rebirth and Hinduism talks about
reincarnation difference is in rebirth
the human will be reborn as a human
whereas in reincarnation the human will
be reborn as a animal or a insect or
another human being it doesn't matter
and the truth is we need to be reborn
yes I mean that's the real truth of the
matter it's like we've all gotten
ourselves broken or you know into
sinfulness and and God's offering us a
way out of that to you know die to
ourselves and and to allow Christ's life
to be accounted to us and the devil just
counterfeits that it's crazy there is no
sin in any of this other right true
that's because you're God and if you
look at the gods that they're modeling
after they're all um defunct morally mhm
you know Shiva is the Destroyer has no
moral code mhm if Shiva follows passions
and lusts and and desires and if you're
God then you're going to do the same
thing so there's nothing it's all
relativism there's nothing to go by as
far as morality goes so there is no sin
yeah and just to add to what Kei said uh
in terms of gender um male and female
both were created in God's image Bible
says that in Hinduism male female and
others
others and Shiva I'm sure we all know
that he's
androgynous and there are there are um
tales in Hinduism where uh God became a
goddess and then he marries a male God
and they basically gender fluid gender
transitioning all these things are
common in Hindu
tales and then another
Sutra written by panjali or supposedly
written by patanjali by unconscious
drives into conscious light one knows
the existence of previous lives again
you will not surely die you will be
reborn or reincarnated so basically the
wise ancient wise serpent took the form
of human being became pangali and in his
writings about yoga the points are
mentioned that you are Divine and you
will not surely die is potentially the
one that wrote that about themselves
like did he say that he used to be a
serpent or is that a a myth that others
wrote about him to my knowledge it's
others who wrote about him other Hindu
Scholars and Hindus who lived M they
wrote about him that he was an ancient
wise serpent so whatever he says
regarding The Serpent and the being
superior to the human race taking the
form or you know interacting through the
serpent all of that even that's true you
know the the serpent was Lucifer for who
was Superior to humans I mean we're made
lower than the Angels yes it's amazing
like just the subtle man he's so subtle
yeah a lot of uh yoga teachers and also
not all yoga teachers there are some
very good yoga teachers who are devote
Hindus they do not deceive Christians
they say it that this is Hinduism if
you're going to do this you are
practicing Hinduism if you stretch for
yoga you are practicing a Hindu ritual
they say it uh there are some some gurus
that they deceive the west and um it's
interesting that I don't know of any uh
popular yoga Guru that wanted to preach
uh or you know teach meditation for
peace in the Middle East you know um to
bring peace between Palestine and Israel
they can go and do the needful to bring
peace in the Middle East I don't know of
anybody who's made an effort to do that
there but they all come here to the west
to the Christian
countries Hebrews 12:2 tells us the
author and finisher of our faith is
Jesus
Christ the author and finisher of yoga
is not Jesus Christ so if as a Christian
a person wants to do yoga for health
benefits then the person is saying by
practice that Jesus is not adequate M
speaking about health benefits on yoga
there are a lot of research materials
that are being published now regarding
side effects of yoga stretching wow I
can name one website nutritionfacts.org
uh Dr Michael Gregory he's actually a
plant-based doctor uh scientist and uh
so he has been putting out a lot of
research materials as to how yoga is not
Superior to any other exercise and it
may may or may not bring
benefits according to research and um
what is the ultimate purpose of yoga
humans are capable of realizing their
real nature and inner self
God from yoga indaily life.org
wow and this is a very this is not um
it's not new to uh practicing Hindu a
practicing um yoga practitioner sorry
yoga practitioner this is not new it
will teach the yoga teaches that a human
is divine and to bring out the Divinity
from the human practice yoga know
thyself that you are God you know once
again just just on that slide real quick
um there the Bible's all about the
relation right relationship between you
and God and the relationship between you
and you your fellow man yeah and it's
like look at this God relationship and
it's all about the union of this this
your soul with God and it's like as a
Christian you know that yoga comes from
other gods like what is that really
telling you I mean they're telling you
in their own words that it's this Union
and this relationship between those two
together I don't think you can just all
of a sudden name whatever God you want
and ascribe it to that you know yeah
absolutely and like I like I always say
offense devote Hindus when Christians
try to christianize yoga mhm uh I think
it's in the book of Jeremiah there's a
verse that says like do not look at how
the heathens worship their gods and say
I will do likewise unto my God
Deuteronomy Deuteronomy okay might be a
couple places but yeah I mean that's
that's clear right there you can't just
say oh well I'm going to take this Hindu
thing and I'm going to do it unto God
and they have that Holy Holy yoga the
Christian Yoga there's a lot of churches
that are open up there not not just a
church group going to a gym no we're
going to open up the doors of the church
and have yoga right inside the church
yes it's wild yes it's
wild so from whom did yoga
originate Lord Shiva says the quote
among the great deities of Hinduism most
personifies the practice of yoga as
yogeshwara the great Lord of yoga ADI
Yogi and Maha Yogi he rules over all
aspects of yoga related to body which is
stretching mind and Consciousness for
those looking to understand the origins
of yoga and the role of all Yoga
practices within it they must first look
to Lord Shiva wow not only related to
historical teachings but as the Eternal
presence of yoga as a supreme
Consciousness behind the universe see
that's what I'm saying by you can't just
take that and ascribe that to God that's
not what they're saying that that's
connection is yeah then according to
Hindu philosophy Lord Shiva the source
of yoga danced the world into existence
and gave it order the universe is thus
viewed as nataraja the cosmic dance of
Shiva because of the new age teachings
that is entered into Christianity when
Christians say that okay talk to God
talk to Universe talk to the Lord talk
to universe that is so wrong in many
levels because universe is not God yeah
it's not Jesus Christ universe is
Shiva um so when when you know Law of
Attraction y so that is also based on
Hindu teachings wow H that's making me
think of Paul said they worship the
Creator or the
creation rather than the Creator like
I'm talking I'm praying to the universe
yeah that's the creation you can't pray
to the creation yeah and uh Shiva also
has no form but he also has form so
people also say he's everywhere and
nowhere at the same time and people
believe that people believe that
unfortunately I think that's the the
funny thing about some some religions
too is like when they do that kind of a
thing like it is it isn't it's like it's
so confusing where God is not the author
of confusion he's very simple in and if
you really just take it you can you can
understand those Concepts that to me
doesn't make sense like a red flag yeah
so Bible tells us where we are point a
that we are Fallen we are sinful and it
tells us point B to have have eternal
life that is the goal right Heaven
eternal life to get from point A to
point B how to get there is Jesus Christ
MH so we know where we are we know where
to go and we also know how to get there
everything is mentioned in the bible mhm
Hinduism is not like
that so first of all as Keith mentioned
there is no concept of sin people say
don't sin yes it people say don't that
don't do this it's wrong and all that
but there is no commandment in Hinduism
what makes it wrong yes there is no
proper definition for that this is what
even my Hindu friends have said and my
Hindu friends are very nice people
Hindus are very nice generally very nice
people is there a moral code that they
try to live by though it's based um it
depends on which cast they belong to and
which DT they worship or God as they
worship it depends on all of those
factors yeah but uh but there is no
specific moral code like like the Bible
has ten commandments and uh you know
Isaiah 8:20 to the law and to the
testimony so we have the Ten
Commandments and the testimonies we
abide by that whether you're in Africa
or Australia India Bangladesh us doesn't
matter it's we all have the same book
The Holy Bible um but in Hinduism it's
not like that because it has various
schools various thoughts and um there
are actually two forms in Hinduism one
is um atheistic and the other one is
theistic and the uh in the theistic form
of Hinduism Shiva is worshiped as a God
and in the atheistic form sh yoga is
part of the atheistic aspect of Hinduism
and Shiva is worshiped as a teacher as a
master so whichever aspect of Hinduism
you choose atheism aism you end up with
Shiva who uses the vas the vas the vas
mostly by the way the word v means
knowledge and it is mostly the um the
atheistic form is considered like Hindu
scriptures or more or less equivalent
yes so there's a vas upat and then the
Bhagavad Gita the vas are very ancient
they're like thousands of years old and
uh and then came the upanishads and then
uh bhagavat Gita bhagavat Gita means
song of the Lord that is the story
between Arjuna and
Krishna so that is bhagavat Gita so The
Vedas are mostly used by the by the yoga
practitioners as they meditate they
chant the mantras and so forth and
that's the athe the atheists have these
mantras and chant yes yes so when I
studied in a Hindu school I was asked to
chant mantras every day and I did that
to me it sounds like chant or Mantra
sounds like a prayer almost so it it's
weird that that would be the atheist
doing that yeah it is also you know
nature worship is involved in that g
nature worship oh wow Captain Planet
yes and um in Hinduism Saturday is the
Unlucky day unlucky day yeah let's
unpack that for a second whoa what makes
it unlucky yeah uh
because you know they associate the days
with the planets like Saturn Saturn yes
Saturn yeah so to reverse the
unluckiness or to make it a better day
you chant
mantras on morning on Saturday mornings
which I used to do that is so
interesting because you know the the
fourth Commandment says to keep that day
holy and yet Satan's like it's unlucky
and you need to chant or pray it away
pray that it's pray the bad luck away
yeah which day is
lucky um Friday is very officious day uh
in Hinduism and a lot of Hindus go to
their temples on on Fridays but these
are um a theistic uh uh Hindus they
believe in God and they go and worship
Shiva and goddesses and so forth
surprised it's not the day of the
sun uh I think it'll get there very soon
because in Hindi ravivar is the Sunday
like an English Sunday Su ravivar is
Hindi Ravi ra from Sun oh okay yeah same
same name in for sun for Sunday first
day of the week W in Hinduism so you're
going to say who this is what he
standing yes yes yes so um so this is a
form of Shiva uh it's called nataraja
and he's called as nataraja in this form
nataraja means lot of dance and acting
and drama
and uh music also evolved from him they
say oh interesting you always hear that
Lucifer was like the chief of music you
his whole body was made up out of
instruments yeah instruments so some um
people say this is a male child yeah and
then some of them say it's not a male
child it is a demon of ignorance and
Shiva is a god of knowledge and so he's
crushing the male child do you ring a
bell male child mhm male child like
Jesus
yeah and which is which is really kind
of a reversal of the prophecy in the
Garden of Eden that you know yeah they
would bite the heel and yes the heel
would crush his King it's a reverse yeah
wow it's a reverse wow this is
interesting I know I I never saw that I
I've seen the statue a million times but
did not know the details of that either
that is fascinating I didn't even knew
knew the details of it I've seen that as
well all my life I've seen it uh it's uh
any Indian um Hindu owned restaurant
will have a statue oh yeah in the US or
anywhere in the world because it's the
most popular form of
Shiva what are some other forms besides
the serpent and this form oh okay so
there is uh there are many forms he has
many many forms uh there's a form called
as d morti in in Sanskrit language
dakshana means south facing morti means
teacher and uh you know viewers can
actually if you can you know Google you
can find Dam morti uh I think it is d a
k s h n as a Nancy a m u r t h y or m r
t i and then you'll see in in Wikipedia
you will see the picture of him from a
temp in at a temple where he's seated
under tree of knowledge who what's with
the crossing of the leg ises that have
some significance yes so one is uh male
the other one is female side oh half
male and half uh half woman half M
male yeah so the dakam
morti he is the teacher that teaches
under the tree of knowledge wow and uh
even at that at his feet there there is
a male mhm is blue H blue in the picture
yeah yeah and most of those temples of
dam Muti form of Shiva they are built
facing the South because he's a south
facing teacher in other words the
devotees have to face a sides of the
north oh
okay I will send the sides of the North
yeah yeah above the clouds yeah I'll be
like the most high yes you see the
parallels yeah a lot of so when a person
is practicing yoga they are linking
their mind with shiva's mind
wow and obviously the Destroyer I mean
it's so opposite than God right I've
come to give them life that they may
have it more abundantly it's the
opposite of Destruction and ruining them
you know yeah and he's the Creator but
Shiva supposedly created out of chaos
which is also taught in mhm science out
of chaos bang explosion but yet it's a
perfect beautiful creation whereas God
he spoke it he spoke it and it became
because he is the truth everything he
speaks comes to existence do you know
why they have put this image at the um
the Gate of CERN CERN and also a G20 a
couple of weeks ago are they all into
this I mean that's the God they're
really serving or what would be the
whole reason for that um the whole
reason is to of course uplift Hinduism
and they believe that it is very closely
connected to science Hindu teachings
really and uh actually the word for
Hinduism is sanatana Dharma Eternal law
sanatana means forever Dharma is law for
example sun rises it's a law of sun to
rise sun sets it's a law of sun to set
so whatever is happening in this world
world it is actually Hinduism Eternal
law so that is actually the right word
for Hinduism ET sonat
Dharma so I just want
to go back to dakam morti part so anyway
so so devotees have to worship Him
facing the sights of the nor so that's
one form and then uh another form is um
he's also an alien because he does not
belong to the human race whereas Christ
belongs to the human race MH he became
name son of man when he's coming back
second time second Advent he's called a
son of man and he calls he he says that
he's our brother yeah so Shiva does not
say that to my knowledge he has never
said I'm your
brother so he is a not of the human
race and um he's also called as a
universe he's also called as a supreme
beggar Supreme beg Supreme beggar yeah
and as you can see there's always a
serpent with him and uh then there's
always a trident yeah a pitchfork a
trident as you could say and then he's
also called as an agori so there are uh
sages or gurus who live in the banks of
the river
Ganges and uh people can look it up if
they like if they like to but I just
want to caution that the pictures may
not be uh nice meaning like um it might
nauseate some people so they worship so
basically these are agori agori gurus
they live in the banks of the river
gandes what they do is they eat dead
bodies wow yeah and the Hindus uh
there's a beliefs in Hindu not all
Hindus there are there is there is a
certain group of Hindus uh that believe
that when a person dies the body has to
be thrown into the river Ganges and if
the ago picks up the body and eats the
body that person is going to Mo heaven
or
Paradise well the person who eats the
body will get no the person who's being
eaten I think so it's it's a good thing
to be eaten by one of these people yeah
I mean isn't that just unhealthy like
how is there not disease just put just
exponentially
perpetuated I'm sure it's an invitation
for demonic possession these people are
probably like the like Legion you know
just hanging around and cutting
themselves the same people that do that
I mean there's at least a
section of Hindus that are largely
vegetarian yes so I'm guessing they
don't belong in that class or or is this
like they make an exception for this
thing there's an exception uh because
these uh these people are called as a
holy men uh in fact many Hindus bow
before them and these men don't wear any
clothes why because of like like we have
yingyang same thing exists in Hinduism
there is no right or wrong everything is
good all is
well um
so yeah that's the way Legion was
described too the guy who was possessed
he was naked hanging out by the tombs
with a lot of dead people like this
interesting and uh very interesting uh
Mikey that is H the connection you made
yeah so so so they worship
uh Shiva and they they believe that
Shiva was the main person who started
this agori
lifestyle and they have ashes on their
body and they live that way all the time
all the time that's their lifestyle wow
these are the ones that you often see
videos of them sitting by campfires and
putting ashes on their foreheads and
stuff I don't know gurus yeah so they
also they practice uh the yoga mhm and
um you know they can withstand a lot of
heat nothing affects them s like
Marshall Arts you know supernatural
abilities these men have these men
possess those abilities uh but these men
are naked and there are few women now
but it's mostly male dominated in fact
yoga itself is male do was male
dominated there was think there's a lot
of women into yoga I mean way more women
into yoga I feel like now now but in the
last several centuries has always been
male
dominated um there was a lady called
Indra Davi uh when she was actually The
prominent female yoga figure but it's
yoga is male do has always been male
dominated and uh this is another form of
Shiva this form he is called as pasupati
pashu Pati means lord of the
beasts he's a lord of the beasts
and um he's also called as a ha d by
archaeologists by archaeologists yes
this is called the pashupati seal it is
in the uh Delhi Museum today it's 5,000
years old approximately according to
archaeologists and it was discovered in
the harapan civilization site which is
actually the North and Northwest part of
India uh haran civilization was the
largest ancient civilization and
advanced civilization it's around 5,000
years old civilization wow and they
found the seal and they said this is
Shiva because uh he has horns and three
faces and is covered with jewelry and
then three faces yeah another
counterfeit I think and then his feet as
you can see are Bine
feet B B words oh okay so like C does
that always say cat like Bale or
something and it's surrounded by Animals
by animals yeah and then uh there's also
goat with long
horns the
goat I mean that that's what I'm saying
like as Christians we just have such an
advantage knowing these symbols of the
goat and The Serpent and all these
things so again this is not 5,000 year
old seal and it exists still today and
this is Shiva
and um it's interesting that the you
know the archaeologist said that he was
covered with jewelry oh precious stones
every precious stone was C discovering
yeah so this is the haran civilization
um the map and it actually extended up
to Iran or Iran and um so they also
found um while Excavating they also
found um what is called as Shiva linga
meaning uh linga means Mark uh Shiva
linga means Mark of Shiva basically it
is a
fallace and the the the base is the you
know the woman and um so it shows the
physical intimacy between the man and
the woman and people worship uh this
form of Shiva
also um and so as you can see source of
yoga Shiva is worshiped as a
mark and this is the shival
linga Mark of the lord of the
beasts it's like the mark of the beast
literally and we're going to look at
this little graphic
now oh
yeah so basically it's all Basilica yeah
it's one and the same so therefore
Hindus say hey Vatican you guys copied
our structure Our God's structure
shivalinga
wow which is it tied into sun worship or
yes yes I say because I've always heard
that this was some kind of symbol of the
sun yeah of the sun wheel M yeah wheel
and wheel is very um predominant in
Buddhist
architecture and that is found in the St
Peters Pica as well so so outwardly it's
everybody's you know fighting that he
Catholicism is better others are saying
Hinduism is better Christianity is
better but when we look at it uh when we
do some research they're all man-made
religions they're all same religions
yeah same religion sorry mhm there's
only one true one true yes that's
interesting because I I do see that
connection like I feel like new age is
like going to be the one world religion
it's the religion that you know you can
be any religion and practice
meditation and and yoga and all these
things and and it's the one that's
saying that like you're like God but we
also know that Catholicism plays a huge
role in the one world religions so yeah
yeah they're kind of just connected
interconnected connected
yes so those are the several forms of uh
Shiva um you can see a lot of like you
know it's interesting when you compare
it next to just the Christian story
story you know and like you you hear the
same similar type things and you know
like it's it's funny because people will
say oh well Christianity just borrowed
from that it borrowed from the Christian
story and just tweaked it you know yeah
and um Mikey mentioned about uh is it
Bale yeah Bale was also called as uh god
of the son mhm for in Canan mhm and uh
similarly because and Shiva is one and
the same of course different regions
different names M uh slightly different
rituals but both have the same you know
horns and boing
feet and uh so if a person worshiping
the son Shiva accepts the worship
because he's a lot of yoga he's a source
of yoga so you're obedient to shiva's
teaching by doing Sun
salutation yeah and bail worship is kind
of a people with would think that's more
like an outdated God or something nobody
worships ba but it's just been replaced
with Shiva I just think it's fascinating
to see all these connections you know
that it's really Satan repackaged he's
he's got a different package for
everybody you know what would you say to
somebody that's like practicing yoga but
is caught in that world of I'm a
Christian but I still like the act of of
yoga how would you how would you begin
to give them practical advice on how to
unravel that
sure if you're doing yoga for health as
a Christian then Bible is your book the
people who live longest and strong they
follow the loss of Health from the
Bible we don't have a community of yogis
living 100 years anywhere in this world
it has never been in the past to my
knowledge whereas you have a community
of people in in lalinda California who
live 100 years and they don't practice
yoga they practice what the Bible
teaches for health so that is my advice
or suggestion or recommendation rather
for people who are looking for health
next please also research uh on um the
side effects of yoga people will have
side effects of yoga uh usually the
people that I have come across that uh
that practice yoga they have gut issues
oh then they also have anger problems
especially the yogis who are into
meditation they have anger
problems and I have not so far have not
met any um yoga practitioner the ones
who do
meditation Eastern meditation say that
oh I have so much joy in my heart in
fact they have always said the opposite
that they have no peace in their
lives and so please do your thorough
research don't just uh practice anything
not only yoga anything for that matter
just because it giving you it's giving
you health benefits just like you read
ingredients before you eat yeah you have
to read the ingredients of your
spiritual or physical practice also what
does it entail uh ingredients in yoga is
Hinduism uh Hindu teaching ancient
teaching that you are sure you are gods
and you will not surely die and also
yoga will eventually
separate the practitioner from Christ it
will not happen in the beginning yeah I
can give you an example so there is a
certain College in California where a
group of uh young Christians joined it's
a Yoga College they joined as a
Christian when they graduated they all
became
Hindus and one of one of the um graduate
um so she was uh from a very um a
popular family uh Christian family and
uh you know her family wanted me to
interact with her and ask I mean answer
her questions and uh so I showed from
her College website that she has been
practicing Hinduism the chanting the
mantras and all that so it is very eye
openening for her she was going to that
college you gave her the information
from the website of the College of the
college yes wow of the college so these
things are there but they are just
hidden from plain side even though
they're right there uh but long story
short she got baptized and she was the
only person so far that came back to
Christianity everybody else all her
friends have gone so far away uh into
New
Age so yoga initially will give you
benefits as you keep on doing it it will
become a spiritual exercise it will and
you won't even know it's happening and
eventually your conscience will be
silenced and you will be separated from
the Holy Spirit which will lead you to
commit the unpardonable sin it is that
serious I I appreciate your your
expertise in this area and you're you're
bringing this to the Forefront I know
we've we've tackled this topic a couple
times but you know I still hear people
try to rationalize this and from what
I'm hearing from you is It's Dangerous
Ground like don't don't
don't compromise in this area yes and
people can also look into nutritional
facts.org and look into the research
that they have been publishing regularly
theyve published a lot of research
content um of the side effects of yoga
and if you and also if you want to
follow the majority you can even look
into you know um people who have left
yoga their testimonies on YouTube
there's there are plenty of westers now
uh that are leaving yoga because of the
negative impact that it cause to them
physic because human body is not
designed to do such type of cont
contractions and um uh so so therefore
it is it is affected them in many many
ways unfortunately the Bible has been
thrown out from schools and Hinduism has
been brought into schools as a form of
Health
message in the West in the west and and
um so that's that's my response and if
you still want to practice yoga well
it's between you and the Lord but please
remember that you are not abiding by
Isaiah 8:20 to the law and to the
testimony one you're also saying by
practice that Jesus is not adequate to
you on the other hand Hindus also will
have a problem with that when you say a
Christian and you're practicing the
ritual it offends them I have good in
Hindu friends very very nice people and
they don't like it when the West
christianized yoga they say in the past
you know they've stolen our gold in the
past now they stolen our yoga
also so crazy in many levels it doesn't
uh
Jive yoga doesn't jive with the
Bible amen awesome like what it says in
Matthew 28 is the words or 1128 yeah and
29 and 30 this is words of Jesus come to
me all you who labor and are heavy laden
and I will give you rest take my yoke
upon you and learn from me for I am
gentle and lowly in heart and you will
find rest for your souls for my yoke is
easy and my burden is light amen can I
read that same verse in
Sanskrit okay I think the Holy Spirit
Led you to read that text cuz that was
the next slide I was about to show so
I'm going to show a clip of this
wonderful young Hindu gentleman who's
studying in a Hindu College a Sanskrit
language and we requested him to read
the same text from Matthew
11 and he's going to read it for us in
Sanskrit and he's going to uh explain it
in English let's listen so basically um
this particular phrase uh any particular
phrase in Sanskrit can have a lot of
different meanings so I'll try my best
according to like my abilities sure so
say this
word because of this Union or this link
my weight reduces burden reduces burden
reduces
okay so what I can make of it is like
this is a sage or this is a uh teacher
or a Guru MH and uh he's like preaching
this to his students or his pupils so
a uh I am
forgiving and polite as well okay that's
why this particular my this Union and
this link and my teachings as well okay
you should take take uh take it on
yourself and uh follow them follow them
okay due to this or using this yeah by
following this you all
uh manasi in your hearts
um uh will achieve Tranquility V I
understand is rest yeah vam is rest but
uh I would say like tranquil is more
okay yeah you can say rest as well rest
rest you'll be at a state of rest or
you'll achieve that state so it's
basically about a union yeah it's it's
like it's about a union or a link link
wow
so the word for um take my yoke upon you
in Sanskrit is similar to
yoga so Jesus is saying yoga with me in
other words link with me as he said
Unite with me Amen on the other hand the
other Guru wants humans to link with his
mind so we have two masters Origins are
different teachings are different
destination is also different
yeah who will you choose it's up to us
wow that was super eye opening I hope
this was a blessing to you guys uh you
know choose ye this day who you will
serve will it be Jesus do you want to be
yoked with with him or do you want to be
yolked with something else Shiva or we
saw the the parallels between Shiva and
Lucifer this is we know that Satan is a
master deceiver he's coming to deceive
the entire world if you enjoyed this
video please give it a thumbs up if
you've never subscribe to this Channel
Please Subscribe share this video with
friends and family and we have a lot of
different ways you can contribute to
this ministry you can so you can donate
through patreon or you can donate
directly from our website or you can
even go to lightwear do shop and buy
some really cool Christian t-shirts that
are good conversation starters it really
helps us out we love you we cannot do
this without you guys and we will see
you next week on LED
[Music]
live
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in 5 minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your
[Music]
journey